as new details emerge about what
happened to the world's greatest golfer
at the hospital he had no recollection
of the crash itself
wow what there was an issue about uh
if he was under the influence some type
of prescribed medication for example
or they did any blood work at the
hospital that would require a search
warrant
to be able to seize that information e.t
has been with tiger for his epic highs
his fall from grace and stunning
comeback in 2019.
i love playing golf but now i'm starting
to love just being around people
we first sat down with woods in 1996. so
what are your plans for the 21st
birthday huh no comment
i've hit the greens with tiger several
times we've discussed his wedding to
then wipe elon nordegren
the whole idea is for us to be private
and
his desire to have kids this is one of
those things where it's
uh you know something i've never
experienced but certainly would like to
one day
tiger's 12 year old son charlie is like
his golf twin
and as for another comeback i've always
been taught by my parents
never to give any thought to anyone's
expectations about yourselves
in the wake of the horrific crash and
tiger's extensive surgeries
fellow golfer rory mcilroy put it all
into perspective
he's not superman he's a human being at
the end of the day and
you know he's already been through so
much at this stage i think everyone
should just be grateful that he's here
that he's alive that his kids haven't
lost their dad
golf is not even on the map at this
[Music]
point